let's go next - let's try the - one five
area code caller from - one five who's
their favorite is rich
go ahead rich what's going on thanks man
yesterday Tuesday the 4th of December
Greg Grandin professor of Latin American
Studies our Latin American history in
New York University was a guest at the
Democracy Now studios in Manhattan and
he was talking about the the national
policies that was made real with Reagan
and then George Herbert Walker Bush and
I have been trying to read myself in and
understand because this is stuff that I
simply just was not taught as a student
I'm I'm about 25 years older than you
but I've been trying to pay attention
and trying to join dots to get a
coherent image and the stuff that
Professor Grandin was was describing
about this transformation of national
policy under Reagan and and then Bush
and the attacks into South America
Central America was was this idea that
was a big shift because you have lineage
to South America and also because you
have lineage to Europe as you moved as
your as your family moved from Europe to
South America this was the wreckage of
the second world war and I mean that's
not that's not my family moved to
Argentina
for World War two okay so was alright so
it was before the wreckage actually was
was created yeah was it was it I
apologize for not having my details
let's go better so what were what we're
dealing with is German nationalism that
was Nazi and then after the war was
called the ratline that populated South
America with these bad guys who ended up
getting cozy with governments of
suppression locally because they had
skill sets gestapo skill sets and one of
the things that popped out of the
woodwork of interest was bariloche and
the this guy caught by ABC News back in
the day this this guy Priebe kid and and
the atrocities that he was responsible
for can Sam Donaldson was able to be
this moment in the 90s of shedding some
light there before that it was the the
discovery and event prosecution of the
butcher of Lyon who's whose name escapes
me now but I don't want to in theirs
we've got 20 people holding is was there
anything in particular you wanted me to
either comment on or a question to
answer being the the point of this
monologue and I apologize is to set you
up for a reply about your awareness of
our national policy having this change
that was George Herbert Walker Bush as a
a product of CIA and his effect in the
Oval Office
first as vice president and as president
and because you have probably a better
perspective being told stuff by family
and then having an interest I would
think possibly that you were able to
follow stuff better than most people
could Spanish Mexicans have a word that
is Malin Shay based on princess Malinche
and her betrayal to the ruler Montezuma
is filling here but I is is there a
question or something you want me to
comment on tell me what you think about
our our wars of intrusion into Central
and South America as our our cordon
sanitaire and how you think it has
affected South America and the freedom
of people's I think about Berta Caceres
having been murdered it's been mostly
disastrous when I moved to the US I was
only five and that's when George George
HW Bush was was inaugurated so at the
time it wasn't anything that I was too
aware of but as I've learned history the
70s 80s and 90s of American intervention
in Latin America although in my country
of Argentina it was more limited to
economics although in other places it
was much more regime changed oriented
although there's a history of that in
Argentina as well which we could talk
about it's basically been disastrous my
it was a discussion topic that for as
long as I can remember is something that
in my family was discussed but as a kid
I wasn't really aware of it because that
was just a kid would when it was going
on really appreciate the call I've got a
bunch of people here who I want to try
to get to